[Music]
hey everyone
welcome to another installment of harry
potter theory
in this video we're going to be
discussing once again
the new fantastic beasts films you've
probably already heard
johnny depp is out as grindelwald and if
you want more info on that
then check out one of my other videos on
the subject in this video
i'm going to be discussing one thing
only why colin farrell
won't be returning as skelet grindelwald
with the joining out
many fans have been left asking who will
be his replacement
which actor they're going to bring in to
save the day
there have been lots of names floating
around as to who will be his replacement
and i even had some ideas of my own mads
mikkelsen
michael fassbender nikolai koster waldow
benedict cumberbatch
etc however for some fans the idea of
bringing back farrell
who already exists in the fantastic
beasts universe is the least painful way
of moving on without johnny
in the first film grindelwald assumes
the form of makusa aura
percival graves aka colin farrell which
effectively means that farrow's
character
is grindelwald just in a transfigured
state of course
later in the film grindelwald's real
form is revealed
and it turns out that he was johnny depp
all along
now that johnny is out fans are asking
can we bring
farrell back here's the issue with that
colin farrell's character
exists in the fantastic beasts universe
entirely independently from grindelwald
he's a real man merciful graves merciful
graves was a presumably
pure blood wizard born in the late 1800s
in the u.s
there's not a lot of info on him on
record however
we do know that he likely attended
ilvermorny's school american hogwarts
and that he was quite magically talented
achieving high grades and general
academic success
we don't know for sure that he was good
at school but it's an inference that's
easy to make
because we know that he became an aura a
career path which
requires high grades and talent in the
realm of magic
after graduating graves is later
employed as an aura by macusa
the magical congress of the united
states of america makusa
is essentially the american version of
the ministry of magic
graves worked his way up the ranks and
eventually became head of macos's
department
of magical law enforcement the
equivalent of the ministry of magic's
head
of the aurora office which in fantastic
beasts is theseus commander
graves new posting meant that he was in
charge of upholding wizarding law
across the entire united states so if
you're a dark wizard at large
who better to transfigure yourself into
than the head of the very department
that is seeking you out at an unknown
date sometime prior to december 1926
graves was successfully impersonated by
grindelwald a transfiguration expert
and was able to leverage graves
authority to get away with all sorts of
nonsense
if it's still unclear the reason that
graves can never be grindelwald is that
his character has a rich history and
backstory
he's a completely different and
independent person whose life we can
trace back to childhood
it just wouldn't make sense that somehow
grindelwald would somehow have to assume
graves form
once again however i will say this
farrell could return to the series as
the real graves
the film never discloses whether
grindelwald actually murdered the real
graves
or if he simply imprisoned him so there
is an opportunity for him to come back
what do you guys think will colin
farrell return as percival graves in
fantastic beasts 3
let me know in the comments section
below until next time
it does not do to dwell on dreams forget
to live
[Music]
you